[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
for today's video we've got a very
special harry potter themed animation
for you guys
that was created in collaboration with
job tunes
the animation is based around the mirror
of erised in the year 2021
so see how many of the pop culture
references you can pick up on
myself silas star wars theory harry
potter folklore
and choptunes all voice different
characters in the video
try and guess who voices who if you
enjoy these types of animations
go and show choptune some love by
checking out his other
harry potter animations i'll put all of
his links in the description
and if you like his content please show
him some love by subscribing
without further ado please enjoy harry
potter
and the mirror of erised
wha the mirror of erised survived the
battle of hogwarts
hmm i wonder what some of my friends
would see hmm
wow i know the function of a rubber duck
i know the function
the function of a rubber duck i know the
function of a rubber duck
hi sheamus wow a baby
congratulations thanks harry we're on
our way to the doctors to find out the
sex
let me save you some time maybe the
mirror can tell you
we're having a gender reveal party we've
got one of those
gender reveal confetti cannons ready
three two one
[Music]
[Laughter]
you will never leave here
fred you're alive oh
[Music]
wait
potter what do you want
now no professor what do you
want
lily what is it really
you i love you so
much i will never let
you go
great galloping gargoyles ari it's me
and i've got a show called the dragon
king
and oh oh
[Music]
come on norberto gonna hide him before
that rudy mcnair gets here you really
shouldn't
burn those wizards
guilty hello harry i'm sorry i don't
have time to talk
merlin's beard this bushy hair i need to
get to the annual minister for magic
conference
[Music]
oh what's this
are there any more questions not
about my hair
been playing the wizarding stocks again
ron yeah
i've got 14 galleons on wizcoin
bloody hell the stocks have tipped my
wiz coin stocks are up 1500 percent
i'm rich harry rich yeah now i can buy
all the things off the trolley
no more combi for me
[Music]
bloody hell leprechaun gold
wow two for one on toilet roll
you don't see that very often what are
you doing
put your mask on i can't i don't have a
nose
i'm so beautiful and harry potter is
dead
what a beautiful day
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]